she delivers in this film she tell her
they all do their mega mega brilliant
stars original Ghostbuster dan Aykroyd
gushes over new Ghost Buster Leslie
Jones and the iconic movie reboot you
love the movie oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely ah you didn't disclose that
the vehicle was gonna be a hearse it's a
Cadillac et cameras captured the epic
moment tuesday night at the el women in
comedy event in LA tonight we are we are
brother and sister in this in this great
great a crusade to bring humor laughter
and joy to the world we're so excited I
saw the movie last night chief you don't
realize how great because she's been
working too hard on SNL unlike some
people out there in social media do you
love the casting do you love the room
who in social media I mean so these are
people who who can't believe it there's
a Supreme Court justice that's a woman I
mean correctly what was the reunion like
with the new cast in the original case
we respect the talent so much that it
for me thrilling you know and then I
think they remember the old days they
remember that Tyrannosaurus but there
they respect the talent I need to ask
you your favorite ghost who was your
favorite goes said the one who took my
belt off when I was lying in bed oh
that's pretty obvious